what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be talking about the biggest
attack on titan secret that the final
season of the anime decided to skip
for some reason i'm referring to the
secret behind
the ackermann clan the one key piece of
information that explains
why the ackermans like levi and mikasa
are so much stronger than
average humans this is a really
important part of the story
i have no idea why the anime left this
out but we're gonna talk about it
right here if you enjoy our attack on
titan content
do me a favor and leave that like it
only takes a second but it really does
help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications before we jump into it
this video was sponsored by surfsharkvpn
in this day and age if you don't want
the government or the marlin military to
control your access to the internet
you need to use a vpn surfsharkvpn
allows you to protect your security and
privacy online
in seconds you just register an account
set up the surfshark extension
on your browser of choice and instantly
your online activity is encrypted
now you have the freedom to surf the
internet and access the content you want
without worrying about corporate or
government restrictions
surf shark gives you easy access to
servers all around the world
and connecting to a server in a
different country means you can get
quick and safe access to all the content
available in that country if online
security and privacy is important to you
just click the top link in the
description and use the promo code
animal pro right now to receive 83
off which gives you the best price on
the market plus
three extra months for free this is a
limited time offer so act
now just click the link in the
description and use the promo code
anime uproar surfshark is available on
windows
android ios mac os smart tvs
and more okay so maybe the anime plans
to cover
this ackermann mystery later on but what
we do know is that when the anime was
adapting the contents of chapter 93 of
the manga which corresponds to episode 2
of the final season of the anime
they left out a part in which zeke
explained why the ackermann clan
is so strong and what makes them
different from ordinary humans
by the way even though this video will
not contain
other major spoilers for the attack on
titan manga i will have to spoil this
specific ackerman secret
in order to talk about it so as far as
that goes
you have been warned so in chapter 93 of
the manga
as zeke is talking to colt and magath
about why the mission in parodies failed
he mentions the two acrements that he
saw on the island
levi and mikasa zeke says that he hopes
to never see them again
because they are such fierce warriors
and he also
reveals why they are so strong
the ackermans are a special bloodline
that was once thought to exist
only in legend even though the ackermans
are subjects of emir just like the other
aldians
they are also different from the others
zeke refers to the ackermann clan as
byproducts of
titan science essentially the ackermans
were experimented on using titan science
in order to create the ultimate warriors
who would protect the king of eldea
over the generations so the ackermans
were essentially bred to be
elite royal guards whose main job is to
protect
lds royal family and as a result of some
sort of titan experimentation that their
clan was subjected to
the acronyms can manifest the power of
the titans
in their human form essentially
they can manifest superhuman powers
including incredible strength and
agility without
ever becoming titans themselves but with
that said
the power of the ackermans has to be
awakened first
according to levi once this awakening
happens
the ackermann in question will suddenly
know exactly what to do
and at this point the superhuman
abilities of the ackermans will manifest
themselves
once an ackermann awakens they instantly
inherit the combat experience of every
ackerman who lived before them through
the paths
and this is what makes the awakened
ackermans like levi and mikasa so
incredibly effective in battle because
this power needs to be awakened
presumably members of the ackermann clan
can go their entire lives without ever
activating the power this awakening must
be triggered by a strong survival
instinct
the power will only kick in when the
ackermann clan member in question
finds himself or herself in an extreme
and life-threatening situation
so for example if we look at mikasa her
power awakened back when her parents
were
killed just as mikasa and aaron were
about to be killed by one of the
criminals
aaron told mikasa to fight this awakened
her ackerman powers
she was suddenly perfectly calm and
incredibly focused
and that is how she was able to kill the
criminal so quickly
and efficiently we also saw that in that
moment her physical strength
suddenly skyrocketed as she snapped one
of the floorboards beneath her foot
on her way to killing the criminal both
levi
and kenny ackerman also experienced
similar moments of awakening before
their powers could be
activated once these powers awaken they
can be used in perpetuity
but an awakening needs to occur first on
top of their superhuman strength and
agility
and their ability to access the combat
experience of the other ackermanns
through the paths
the ackermann clan is also immune to the
founding titan's ability
to manipulate the memories of the other
subjects of emir
and this is why the ackermann clan was
persecuted within the walls
and why only a few members remained by
the time that the main storyline got
going
basically the ackermans refused to
accept king fritz's
pacifist ideology which led the king to
abandon many fellow aldians on the
continent
as he sought peaceful refuge behind the
walls
when king fritz decided to manipulate
the memories of all the aldians within
the walls so that they could forget the
outside world
this memory manipulation didn't work on
the ackermanns
the same was of course the case with the
asian clan who were also
immune to the memory manipulation
because the ackermans knew that the
reality within the walls was a lie
and because they opposed the founding
titans ideology
they were perceived as a threat and so
they went from elite royal guards to
persecuted
outcasts the ackermanns were nearly
wiped out by the authorities within the
walls until the head of the ackermann
clan gave himself
up to be executed in exchange for
sparing the lives of the
other ackermanns part of the compromise
included the surviving ackermanns
agreeing to withhold the truth about the
outside world from their children
and so future generations of the
ackermanns became just as ignorant as
everyone else within the walls
even after the remaining ackerman's lost
all knowledge of the outside world
the ackermann family continued to be
persecuted in one way or another
until yuri rhys finally stopped it after
meeting
kenny ackerman this decades-long
persecution and oppression of the
ackermanns is why there are so few of
them left at the beginning of the attack
on titan's story
the only known living acronyms at the
time that the story begins are mikasa
levi
and kenny mikasa's father was of course
killed several years earlier by those
kidnappers
presumably before ever having a chance
to awaken his power
and levi's other family members also
died years ago
so that is the secret of the ackermann
clan
their bloodline is a byproduct of titan
science
meaning that due to titan
experimentation that was conducted on
the bodies of their
ancestors the current ackermanns are
able to manifest the superhuman
abilities of the titans without ever
turning into titans themselves
this is a pretty major reveal and it
answers so many previously unanswered
questions
in the story so why do you think that
the anime decided to skip
this reveal will the final season of the
anime neglect to mention this
all together or are they just saving it
for a future episode
maybe they want to give this revelation
more attention and in the manga when
zeke
initially talks about it he only
mentions it briefly in passing
either way definitely share your
thoughts on this entire ackermann
mystery
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this attack on titan video and
you want us to keep it going please
leave that like it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications
you really have to go through the
trouble of hitting that bell and then
selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at animeopror as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you